[Music]
this film presents
the neurological examination of infants
in the first week of life
in most instances the normal responses
are followed by examples of
various types of abnormality which may
be encountered merry remarks
seem needed first this is clearly only
one scheme of examination
the sequence in which the test done will
have necessitated
somewhat from baby to baby depending on
initial state
in some cases other examinations not
included here may need to be added
secondly the matter of interpretation is
beyond the scope of
a film of this length in only a few
instances
our abnormality is clearly diagnostic or
indicative for treatment other
abnormalities may
clearly be deviations from normal at the
time
but may be transient and may be followed
by entire future normality of the baby
in many cases our present state of
medical knowledge does not permit us
either to
explain the abnormality or give any
prediction prognostically for the future
many items of examination must evaluated
by observation of the infinite rest
preferably with minimal handling the
head is observed for the position of the
eyes at rest
spontaneous movements of the face are
observed
and the palpebral fissures checked for
width and equality
one abnormality to be looked for is the
setting sun
sign as in this case of kernicterus
which consists of the irides appearing
to set beneath the lower lid
so that white sclera may be seen between
the iris and the upper lid
unequal palpebral fissures may be the
most obvious physical sign of facial
paralysis
if the infant is not actively moving the
face
this example is a rather drowsy infant
with neonatal meningitis
the marcus gun phenomenon consists of
congenital ptosis
in which the lid is automatically
elevated each time the joys moved in
sucking
spontaneous movements of the body as a
whole and of the limbs are observed
the character of the movements and the
range of motion of the joints should be
appraised
one should look for possible abnormal
movements including tremulousness
spontaneous writhing movement myoclonus
or convulsions
in word nick holland disease the baby is
flaccid and aeroflexic
respiration show bulging of the abdomen
and retraction of the chest
birthingly of the spinal cord
superficially resembles word [ __ ]
hoffman disease
the abnormal posture of the arms is the
most obvious difference aside from other
responses to be demonstrated later
the posture of the arms alongside the
head is often one of the most initially
striking features of mongolism
[Music]
irregular jerking writhing movements are
characteristic of many normal premature
infants
the earliest observed fetal activity is
often athetic in nature
and this type of movement appears to
persist for a time after premature birth
jittery tremulous activity may be seen
spontaneously or may be obtained in
response to almost any stimulus
handling sound light or eliciting the
moral reflex may show the tremulous
movements
unlike jitteriness myoclonus is always
an
abnormal spontaneous movement in this
example the pathologic basis is obscure
although the infant was subsequently
microcephalic with [ __ ] dipleture
the baby remained fully conscious and
had a normal electroencephalogram
this is an example of convulsive
movements in an unconscious baby with
abnormal electroencephalogram
neonatal convulsions are usually based
on trauma
or anoxia at birth or on chemical
abnormalities
the causation in this case is obscure
but the disease was familial
and presumably metabolic although no
abnormal substance could be identified
in the urine
admirable posture of the left arm is
obvious in this case of brachial palsy
however it is not complete as some
movement can be obtained in response to
pinprick
the blink reflex delight is tested with
a welch alum light or a strong
flashlight
blinking should be obtained even if the
baby's eyes are closed
unless the baby is crying so that the
eyes are already held maximally closed
an absent blink reflex seldom indicates
blindness
cortical or ocular more often as in this
example
it is due to general depression of the
central nervous system from anesthesia
anoxia or other causes
response to sound is tested with a
wooden clacker
the response obtained may consist of a
blink a startled jump
or a moral reflex this response is
particularly hard to obtain
in many instances and should be repeated
before one concludes that it is missing
palmer grasping is tested by applying
the examiner's finger firmly against the
palm of the hand
from the ulnar side
the palmer grasp response may be absent
for a variety of reasons
including wordnig hoffman disease as in
this example
[Music]
plantar grasp is similarly tested
applying the finger to the sole of the
foot near the base of the toes
the knee jerk is the only tendon reflex
of major clinical value in most newborns
it is tested in the conventional manner
but the head should be in the midline at
the time of testing
the knee jerk may be absent as in this
case of wordnick hoffman disease
or from central nervous system
depression due to anoxia or other causes
an exaggerated knee jerk is seen in this
baby with
myoclonus
ankle clonus is best tested by pushing
lightly against the sole of the foot
the entire leg being free in the air
often none is obtained
but a considerable number of beats may
be elicited in many normal infants
the average number of beets obtained
should be recorded
this baby shows ankle clonus which is
sustained for eight or ten beats but
nevertheless turned out to be entirely
normal
slower more vigorous ankle clonus of
greater amplitude is sustained
indefinitely in this baby with
generalized myoclonus
the rooting response is tested by
touching each corner of the mouth
and the upper and lower lip in the
midline the infant's head will normally
follow in each direction
but sometimes movement of the face and
tongue only is obtained
this reflex may be reinforced by
previous testing of the sucking reflex
if necessary
sucking is tested with the examiner's
finger in the infant's mouth
the finger being covered with a finger
cut for sterility
an absent rooting response and very
feeble sucking are seen in this case of
congenital wardnig hoffmann disease
another case of wordnick hoffman disease
still active with incomplete atrophy
shows a visibly fasciculating tongue the
fasciculation is often most easily seen
on the under surface of the tongue
normally when an infant is picked up and
placed in the prone position with a head
in the midline
the baby will lift up its chin turn the
head to one side
and make crawling movements with the
feet and sometimes with the hands as
well
the arm may be extended on the side
toward which the head turns
vertical eye movements may be evaluated
by moving the head upward or downward
the eyes tend to remain fixed toward the
examiner in a manner rather like the
eyes of a dog
to test the labyrinthine reflex the
examiner holds the baby vertically
facing him
and turns first in one direction then in
the other
the effect can best be illustrated with
the research apparatus which rotates
baby and camera together at the same
speed
during rotation the baby looks ahead in
the direction of rotation
on stopping the infant looks back in the
opposite direction
sometimes only forced deviation of the
eyes is seen
but nystagmus is usually observed in
vigorous mature infants
the tonic neck reflex is tested by
turning the child's head
slowly to the right or left and
maintaining it in this position for
about half a minute
the shoulders should be kept horizontal
a positive response consists of
extension of the arm and leg
on the side toward which the joys turn
and flexion of the opposite limbs
there may be pelvic rotation in addition
no constant pattern is obtained in the
majority of newborns whether normal or
not
this baby who subsequently turned out to
be entirely normal
shows fairly consistent tonic neck
reflexes particularly in the legs
even these are not obtained on every
occasion however
and repeated rotation of the head is
necessary to evaluate the response
so
this drawing illustrates a strong
obligatory response which the infant
cannot overcome by struggling
this is abnormal at any age
the traction response is tested by
lifting the infant from the supine
position by pulling on his arms
there should be assistance from the
baby's shoulder muscles
which can be felt by the examiner
when the infant is nearly to the sitting
position
the head should be brought forward and
there should be sufficient tone in the
neck muscles to keep it from dangling
helplessly against the chest
at the end of the test
the traction response may be absent for
a variety of reasons
as in this case of congenital wardnig
hoffmann disease
in mongolism the traction response is
also missing
the universal hypotonia becomes evident
in testing this response
an asymmetric traction response absent
on the paralyzed side
is seen in a left-sided brachial palsy
the withdrawal response is tested by
applying a pin to the sole of the foot
facial evidence of pain should also be
looked for
as failure to withdraw the stimulated
limb may be due to either anesthesia
or paralysis the pin should be applied
rather forcefully
as a gentle pinprick may elicit a
response of extension
rather than withdrawal
this baby with wordnig hoffmann disease
shows no withdrawal to pinprick
but there is clear evidence of pain in
the facial expression
an automatic jerky withdrawal is seen in
this baby with spinal cord injury
there is no evidence of appreciation of
pain until the upper level of anesthesia
is reached
a striking crossed extension reflex in
the opposite limb may be seen in many
cases of spinal cord injury
the tonic neck reflex may modify crossed
extension
automatic withdrawal and lack of
appreciation of pain are clear in this
other case of court injury
the suggestion of crossed extension is
only obtained when the infant is
supported in the upright posture
spontaneous stepping movements may be
obtained in most infants if one supports
them erect
placing the soles of the feet firm on
the surface and inclining the trunk and
head
forward or intermittently from side to
side
most mature infants show these stepping
movements at one time or another but
not on every occasion
to test the placing response the infant
is again supported in the erect position
and the dorsum of first one foot and
then the other is drawn upward against
the under surface of the table edge
the baby should lift its foot upward and
place it firmly on the table surface
the placing reflex is poor and feeble in
this baby
but he is quite normal except for being
fatigued from a long examination
the placing response was vigorous on
another occasion
the trunk incubation reflex can be
tested by stroking the paravertable
areas
it can also be evoked by pinching the
skin just above the pelvic brim
the moral response can be tested in a
variety of ways
but is most reliable and most complete
when elicited by supporting the baby
under back and head
and letting the head drop back about 30
degrees
normally the arms first extend and then
flex the femora also flex on the pelvis
in moses's
an absent moral reflex may be due to
word negothman disease or more often to
depression of the central nervous system
an abnormal stiff type of morrow is seen
in kernicterus
brachial palsy produces an asymmetric
moral
in this example the paralysis is on the
left
the right arm produces a normal moral
response while the left arm fails to
participate
the tone of the neck trunk and limbs has
been evaluated during the previous
examinations
it may be tested further by manipulation
of the limbs
the baby should also be suspended in the
supine
lateral and prone position on the
examiner's hand
as in this case of kernicterus is best
appreciated in the milder cases
if the baby is placed on its side and
attention directed at retraction of a
head
in more severe cases there may be
hypertonus in all postures
universal hypotonia is one of the most
striking signs of mongolism in the
newborn
congenital contractures and limitations
of motion
are striking in this case of
arthrogryposis multiplex congenita
this baby also has club feet which are
treated by strapping
completely flaccid legs with absolute
movement are seen with myelomeningocele
trans illumination of the head should be
carried out in total darkness with a
strong
flashlight fitted with a light tight
seal
one should attempt to trans-illuminate
from occipit to forehead
against the baby's forehead and from
side to side
with the flashlight in any of these
positions but especially anteriorly
a faint glowing subcutaneous halo around
the circumference of the flashlight is
normal
larger irregular and brighter areas may
show the presence of an abnormality and
indicate further testing
side to side or back to front trans
illumination
when seen from the side opposite the
flashlight
may appear as a total glowing over the
entire head
such an extended area is usually due to
hydroencephaly
a normal head of course will transmit no
light at all
the reaction of the pupils to light
should be tested
noting the size of the pupils before the
light is turned on
and the speed of constriction
a congenital cataract usually appears as
an
obvious opacity in the lens although
there are several possible forms
ophthalmoscopic examination is begun by
inspection of the pupil
cornea and lens and followed by
examination of the eye grounds in the
conventional manner
madrid drops are required for adequate
observation
and the assistance of a nurse is usually
needed
if the examination has been done as part
of the collaborative study of the
national institutes of health
the last two items on the forum concern
conditions during examination
and opinion as to normality by
conditions this meant the examiner's
opinion
whether or not a satisfactory emission
of this baby was obtained
the diagnosis is an overall clinical
impression of formality or abnormality
if a baby is believed normal in spite of
certain deviations from the usual
findings
these may be indicated in the round
column
finally if a diagnosis of abnormality is
based on
inability to obtain an expected response
normally present
one should clearly repeat the
observation at the end of the
examination
or preferably on another occasion before
concluding that it cannot be obtained
you